yeah so so what's the best way for me to
start investing in bitcoin
do i use do i use one of these alt coins
like litecoin or ethereum
well there's literally thousands and
thousands of
altcoins now right and uh and they're
all just
so what's the difference between most of
these altcoins and
the original bitcoin
they all have various some of them like
litecoin i told you about
they were just like they even like
dubbed themselves when they came out
like
bitcoin is gold and we'll be silver they
had a faster block time
there's gonna be more of them emitted in
the end because of that faster block
time pretty sure
and um but literally it was just a copy
and paste of the code there's no new
functionality just kind of rebrand it
and make money
and it worked out and it's still a
fairly valuable
coin you know despite what is so so then
there's a lot of other ones though that
um
they'll add functionality of some kind
so there's a lot of experimentation
happening so ethereum
yeah this kid vitalik right he's getting
flown
he's meeting with vladimir vladimir
putin and the kremlin and he's all over
like what's he's canadian and he is uh
but he's a russian son of russian
immigrants so he's a scary looking kid
he's funny there's lots of really funny
memes of who i bet
i bet this is a famous meme
uh vitalik laughing anyhow i've met him
uh in 2014 at a conference before
ethereum launched
and uh he was just a kid that was
writing for uh
bitcoin was it bitcoin magazine yeah
bitcoin magazine he was just doing some
writing for them
and he was super interested in bitcoin
he was a programmer
and uh i mean at the time he wouldn't
have been over 20 years old
and um and so yeah he just uh
i think he actually was trying to pitch
some of his ideas to the bitcoin
uh sort of core developing team the guys
who kind of maintained bitcoin
um but in the end he just ended up
launching ethereum
and it's basically a smart con it's
called a smart contracts platform
so it just adds a bunch of that's what
ethereum is yeah it adds a bunch of
sort of a code layer on top of the
currency and actually he never really
envisioned
according to him he never envisioned
ethereum itself being like a currency
it's just
it's just the the token that everything
runs on
on his on on all these smart contracts
so smart contracts can do things like uh
basically instead of bitcoin where you
just okay i want to send it to you i'm
going to send it to you now okay did you
get it yes i got it
bitcoin can do some other things and it
can actually do smart contracts too
it just hasn't really been built out but
instead of that you can make a lot of
more complicated
a lot more complicated uh things happen
on ethereum
like uh you can make a smart contract
that say if you put
your coins in it uh it'll send them out
to
everybody in three weeks or something
they'll send them out to these four
people
or something like that or if uh if you
want to have a job done or something you
could
send it to a smart contract and once you
you know that way the
the guy doing the job knows that the
funds are there and locked in the smart
contract and then
maybe once you guys both agree that
everything's done to satisfaction then
the funds get dispersed whoever needs
them
and then there's lots of more
complicated uh
use cases but one of the one of the main
ones that's happening right now like as
we speak
that's kind of a big deal you asked me
where can you get bitcoin
okay where can you get this that was
your initial question um
so the answer to that a year ago well
the answer that now is still
there's centralized exchanges so there's
there's people who have set up services
like the one i told you about earlier
bid instant where you just buy
bitcoin with the credit card one of the
earliest ones well the earliest one i
think was
one called mt gox
which uh stands for magic the gathering
online exchange
oh yeah i've heard of that one uh it was
a it was a
it was basically ebay for it was based
in japan
for trading magic cards which is like a
yeah i know it's a target
yeah so
you know so they had this like
marketplace kind of thing
and the owner of the guy that bought it
was this french guy uh what was his name
well i came from can't believe i forgot
his name anyhow
he uh he bought it and
decided that he wanted to add like a
bitcoin market like okay he can buy
bitcoins here
and so he just put a thing up where they
were selling bitcoins because i guess he
was mining them or whatever
and it became like a huge thing and then
they
ditched the they kept they were still
called mount gox or mtgox
they ditched the card trading thing all
together it was gone they just became a
bitcoin exchange
really so you could wire them money and
then they would send you bitcoin or ach
money to them
and there were no restrictions pretty
much whatsoever
but they went down in 2014 kind of
epically
how did they go down um i think it was a
hack
um it could have been an inside job it's
still under investigation oh and it lose
like millions and millions of dollars
lots of money it was in happened
sometime in early 2014
they their website went down for first
what happened first they'd have a bunch
of scares first of all
like it wasn't very well run so they'd
have a bunch of they'd had problems for
like
ever uh with scale you know scaling to
meet this huge demand that was coming in
and and and so they'd have problems and
they usually had fixed them and they had
like a big lead in the whole
network network effect like they were
the big name
and uh yeah then one day i think in like
january february of 2013
they stopped doing bitcoin
withdrawals so they suspended with
bitcoin withdrawals
and people were like whoa what's going
on with that and then um
they're uh their website was still up so
people could still log in and
and you could actually trade bitcoin
between users
still and so this one guy had this
brilliant idea
it was really brilliant he made it he
made another exchange
he called it bitcoinbuilder.com
and so he was like okay if you send me
your coins on mount gox i'll credit you
on my website
and you can exchange your mount gox
coins for real bitcoin
for people who want to deposit and buy
so it's a way for basically
people to speculate on whether they
thought mount gox would come online
again or not
which i actually took in and lost really
i know some people lost a lot of money
doing that though so yeah it was
it was dumb of me but so yeah basically
i went on and bought i
sent bitcoin to this guy
bitcoinbuilder.com and i bought
so if if i had sent one bitcoin in there
or something i could buy like
four gox coins right because everybody's
so if mount gox just was like okay
everything's fine bam i would have had
four bitcoin
right basically that i could have
withdrawn but of course that's not what
happened they went down
one day their website went down and and
it came out later that they were hacked
and then there was another exchange
implicated that went down a couple years
later called btc-e they're a russian
exchange
and they um the fbi took them down
somehow i don't know but really they
said they were implicated actually in
the mount gox
hack so i think mike got that that's
still on like the people who
have like a bankruptcy claims against
mount gox
because bank they filed bankruptcy so
anybody who had coins there could
maybe get something back through the
bankruptcy process
it's still ongoing as far as i know what
happened to all those coins that got
stolen
uh they went out and got laundered
through fairly
various places i think bt btc-e
was involved in that somehow but again
you can kind of track them
like theoretically you can track them
but um
i'm not sure if since it's all under
investigation i'm not sure if
that has been made public what happened
to them oh
yeah you would think it would all be
trackable right you'd be able to fight
figure out where everything went
right but i don't know i'm sure there
are people i'm sure there are people who
have gone down that rabbit hole i
haven't particularly but
that brings me to a sort of another
point though
um there's a saying in crypto since
we're talking about exchanges and how to
buy it
there's a lot of exchanges now in the us
um
it's not like the old days though where
you just send money and you get bitcoin
back like it's pretty
heavily regulated now um which has its
good things and it's bad things
uh i'd say mostly bad but uh
you know they have to verify who you are
like follow all the sort of
any money laundering know your customer
laws
the big ones are coinbase and gemini of
those two i kind of like gemini better
um gemini that's the winklevoss yes and
gloss twins
lost twins the gemini twins right okay
that's their exchange that they built
and um but the thing is
when you hold when a lot of people and i
know a lot of people who've been in
bitcoin for a long time they still do
this
they leave their coins on the exchange
like in the exchange wallet
and essentially what you're doing then
is you're you're you're holding your
coins
in somebody else's ledger just like you
have it in a bank
like like uh like if you have your money
in your bank
uh if that bank becomes insolvent or
something
uh there's fdic insurance which is
another rabbit hole
to ensure you but essentially that
money's gone if somebody's
you know if the bank becomes to solve it
but if these exchange so when mount gox
became insolvent and went under and
those coins got
i mean it was game over for i know
people that lost hundreds of bitcoins
on mount gox and uh
so it was it's just it's just gone man
you know
wild west you know yeah and so
whenever you're sending them to these
exchanges you're you're you're taking
your bitcoin which is
kept track of on the bitcoin blockchain
so that means you have an account
balance
on the bitcoin blockchain ledger you
know that's the one that i told you that
shared across
all the computers and everything um
there's short of the entire internet
shutting down
there's nothing that can really take or
you losing
your access to those by losing you like
not taking care of your security well
enough or losing your
you know your hard drive dies and you
didn't have backups short of that
there's nobody can take that
money from you that is this bitcoin from
you nobody can go and seize them
easily unless they physically take your
computer and force you to
send them out you know
but once you put them on third party
exchange
it's just an entry on their bank ledger
they don't they
they control the actual asset the
bitcoin you don't control it anymore so
if they go under if they get hacked or
whatever
your stuff's all at risk of that and
they're pretty big you know a lot of
these changes they're pretty big honey
pots you know
hackers are always trying to get into
these exchange wallets right
they've gotten very good at the
exchanges have gotten very good at um
securing the coins how the hell do you
pay taxes on your bitcoin
if it's so volatile the price goes up
and down well what if you would have
bought it at like
ten thousand dollars and but in december
it's worth the 30s handles it is
if you um it's just like any other
investment
so the same thing with stocks like you
can hold a stock you can go up to 100
and then back down to what you bought it
for
you know it's uh they they count it
whenever you convert it back to us
dollars
so that's the taxable event that's when
you
convert oh okay yeah so you can hold
bitcoin you can buy it a hundred dollars
and then
it goes up to 1300 and it goes back down
to 200.
as long as you didn't sell at any point
in there there's no
taxable event okay so
but there's the and the crypto universe
and uh
taxation is a is a nightmare frankly i
bet
um yeah you'd have to get like a
specialized uh
accountant if you're doing anything
crazy with crypto to deal with that but
if you're just you know buying the coins
and holding them
stuff like that it's pretty
straightforward just like buying
anything else and holding it
okay
foreign